à celle ni le moral des salariés est en
berne après des mois de difficultés et
de chômage partiel le tribunal de
commerce a prononcé la liquidation de
l'entreprise
3 - de poursuite d'activité avec le
mince espoir de trouver un repreneur
une sensation de gâchis une sas assure
d'écoeurement une sensation aussi de
savoir fédérer par nos dirigeants qui
nous ont promis pendant des années que
que c'est ni voulait le garder qu'on a
et qu'ils allaient ramener de l'argent
qu'on allait innover des nouveaux
moteurs tout ça et au bout du compte le
whif ça a gâché parce que on avait
peut-être la possibilité de sauver et
puis bah on nous a parlé cette fois une
situation qui rappelle de douloureux
précédent fa com en 2006 130 deux
ouvriers au chômage un bâtiment
aujourd'hui à l'abandon et route au
volant de 1778 licenciements et un site
rasé depuis dernier en date l'entreprise
de luminaires silent enhco 83 emplois
supprimés en octobre 2016
le secteur a souffert même si les
derniers signes sont plutôt
encourageants les entreprises notamment
industrielles comment sera réinvesti
donc rire lorsqu'un entrepreneur à chef
d'entreprise investis
ça veut dire qu'il ya réellement des
projets et qu'il ya une volonté de
développement et que le carnet de
commandes se remplit donc ça c'est
positif à coulanges cette entreprise
fait de la découpe laser 19 salariés en
2015 30 aujourd'hui et des
investissements croissants
ici on veut croire à l'avenir de
l'industrie nivernaise faut arrêter la
nièvre aux dans la nièvre
il ya du travail il y as d'activité il
ya des pépites ya très belle entreprise
la fusion ça fait en elle dans les cinq
plus gros laseris français a rayonné
dans la nièvre
malgré un certain déclin ces dernières
années le secteur de l'industrie
représente toujours 15% des entreprises
de la nièvre et près de 20% des
effectifs du département